sus habitantes lo describen como un
pueblo tranquilo la comuna de confianza
antonio fue golpeada por un hecho
violento este viernes los profesores que
trabajan en este sector están asombrados
y los padres de los alumnos
profundamente molestos tenemos 15 días
para reconstruirnos un poco y
tranquilizar al pequeño es algo
complicado por suerte la escuela ya
había terminado los estudiantes también
están traumatizados
no era mi maestro pero lo había visto me
sorprende porque nunca más volvería a
verlo el asombro y la indignación
también se toma la clase política este
sábado el ministro de educación nacional
jean-michel blanca se reunirá con
representantes del personal y los padres
de los estudiantes esta noche la
república es atacada con el asesinato de
uno de sus servidores un profesor esta
noche pienso en él en su familia nuestra
unidad y firmeza son las únicas
respuestas a la monstruosidad del
terrorismo islamista
varios políticos condenaron unánimemente
el ataque